I've been repeating this all day today
and it was I was upset
choked embarrassed kind of ashamed me to
be honest um because the reason why for
the work that I do and where that
Chelsea do to regard them to educate the
unbrace ISM at the club so to see that
it was like I was awoken and it was 12
in the night and to see a message what I
didn't understand until I saw the video
yeah I was couldn't believe it
where was where is it coming from
because when you started out playing for
Chelsea we're talking few decades gay
now aren't we but things were very
different or least we hope they were
differently was a pretty unpleasant
experience by the time it was um I
didn't expect I was a young lad seeking
his dreams have been a professional
footballer making it debut and was
against Crystal Palace and not knowing
anything yeah just want to get on the
pitch and here's this opportunity now
for the second half to be yeah into the
the fray of it and before so doing my
warmup start to hear this racist abuse
me try that me and not 9 it was coming
thinking it was the Crystal Palace
support and it was coming from my my own
supporters a minority there suppose was
give me that abuse girl very much hope
the things have changed since those days
actual fact things having people to kick
about campaign things like that is this
an isolated incident or are we seeing a
rise or the ugly face of abuse from
Gilligan well we all hope it's not an
isolated incident but I think what is
important to recognize is we can't in
football afford to be complacent that's
the first thing racism has its ugly face
each other's twists it has its turn so
you have got to keep pace with it and
that's why it's very important that we
we're not complacent and we take it very
seriously
I think what's been very important in
the developments over the last 24 hours
is the response from Chelsea Football
Club or Chelsea Football Club are doing
is they're almost self policing what is
taken what took place in that subway in
Paris was pretty much on the streets
it's a civil situate
wasn't in football wasn't it Stamford
Bridge you efer and it was a European
game but made absolutely clear these
outside of our remit but Chelsea all
created them and said if these are
Chelsea fans we will take appropriate
action and I think that's commendable
because what kicking out has been trying
to do for a number of years is to get
clubs to self-police
and we are at a groundbreaking stage now
where Chelsea have taken upon themselves
to go beyond their remit to help the
French authorities to help the
Metropolitan Police and say look if you
can prove these are Chelsea fans and if
they have season tickets are our members
we will deal with it that's a great
message of football which is very
encouraging indeed but what do you think
Chelsea are going far enough I mean a
statement is easy to put out as many
ways but should we see for example Roman
Abramovich coming out and actually
saying something or impact some the
senior players making a statement as
well as showing that they're actually
more serious about it let me say the
days yet and you might see them coming
and right now as Graf said I'm chassis
opinion getting on top of it and
reacting to the earth situation right
away and that's what I like a bag it
needs to be they're not dragging the
heels about this it's quite a serious as
I said my question is are they real sub
chassis suppose that's what we got
understand first and then they kick next
question the original friends and real
fans were there that were there on that
tube they do know them and if they do
split them out and we'll get them out
the reaction of some of the other people
who are on that tube saying oh no this
wasn't a racist attack I saw you both
actually sort of almost sort of you know
blinking and amazement at that it what
I'd be interested know what they what
they would perceive it to be it's not a
racist attack a lot to know what is the
only thing there was absence there that
that on optical occasion was the
violence and I think that it wouldn't
have taken much to spark violence I
think anybody who any reasonable person
would have seen that video footage would
have been appalled by it but I think
what is important to recognize now is
that we have a situation
where
in football and in society there are
people clearly saying things in private
they're not prepared to say in public
and it's quite clear to me that if those
racist thugs in that subway in Paris
have known that been on camera
they'd have modified their behavior but
this is something that's symptomatic in
football this seems to be this this this
this behavior where we know quietly
things are said that shouldn't be said
and I think this is the next stage of
our development to kick it out with the
football authorities and with clubs in
particular to deal with situations we've
got to say in the dressing room and in
the boardrooms look you know these are
working environments we cannot allow
people to say things that either in
private or publicly certainly not
publicly but in private that they think
they can get away with we've got to
actually announce it and present it as
it is and for what it is but this was a
situation that was outside beyond
football scope so I commend Chelsea for
getting involved at the same time though
when we look at the number of banning
orders that Chelsea's got against fat
it's actually low compared to a lot of
other clubs I mean this is just perhaps
in a bit of inertia going on well it's
been unfair I know that is I'm sorry
when you consider what I'm saying when
you consider the amount of work the
Chelsea have done and I and I'm not a
proposal for Chelsea
I find myself I think it's quite
interesting the [ __ ] itself sort of
defending the club almost but I have to
acknowledge that the Chelsea have worked
very very hard and been in almost
immediate I got information of this
particular incident at 7:30 this morning
by 8:15
Charlie's responding do you think I mean
you know you were the first ever black
player but now we see several black
players with Chelsea and in fact across
the game as a whole they're much more
common but do you think this puts off
young talent or wholesome bad boy a
lovely young handsome regardless um as I
said from Chelsea have stepped up their
game in dealing with a matter right away
a young lad coming into football he will
not be discarded what you see in their
choice is a very big
as many other arsenal or man unite and
they're dealing with the situation of
racism done come on it creeps but when
it quit we get on top of it and that's
what we're doing here solutely well does
it ever option we deal with it very
heartening to hear that good both in
here thank you